hey this is funny that we have a
voicemail number that number is two one
nine two david p there's a caller who's
been calling and off and on for years i
know him as the kansas troll and this is
a guy who once called sam cedar to argue
about sam cedar fellow progressive host
to argue with sam about the bell curve
and you can see this viral clip on sam's
channel it's called something like
stupid young man or racist young man
calls in to argue about race or
something like that
it's the kansas troll this is the same
guy and he's gotten through it to me
live before he talked to me something
about alex jones as supplements or
something like that
he called in and he had a critique to me
about how the show is doing take a
listen to this hey back minute I mean
hey members membership salesman how's it
going buddy I see that uh after your
advertisers have fallen down a bit
you're selling a lot of memberships I
mean most of these internet shows
they're asking for ten if you used to
ask for seven that he went down to five
and now you're offering two dollars a
month for membership over George Pakman
just operate for free that's what it's
worth it this provided you're not gonna
get more members your shows gonna fail
gonna collapse soon you've been doing
this for over ten years it's not going
anywhere just give it up Dave you know
when I hear that I I would love to see
what this guy's been up to over the last
ten years and what's what's amazing
about this is that first of all
membership prices have been unchanged
for something like eight years and a lot
of shows raise membership rates we've
kept the same rate six a month sixty a
year for a very very long time and of
course we offer discounts to people who
can't afford to pay the full rate what's
funny about this is that we are
regularly contacted by other shows
independent shows media outlets the rap
interviewed me last week specifically
about how we've built this membership
program because it's so successful
that's what's incredible and in 2019
alone so we run the membership program
since 2010 we doubled nearly doubled our
members in 2019 so from 2010 to 2018 we
grew membership
in 2019 alone we have nearly doubled
membership since 2018 it's incredible
actually how it's doing and you know
this is a guy who's been calling in for
a very long time saying we're just
circling the drain the show is you're so
close to going off the air and you know
someday that may happen
noth-nothing last forever but not today
and certainly not tomorrow my friends so
when I hear stuff like that that
actually is what gets me fired up to say
we want to have the best 2020 ever
thanks to everyone who's already
supported us this year let's try to
double membership again in 2020 and
those are the types of folks where I I
used to be really bothered by stuff like
that and then I imagine has this
person's business doubled in size
over the last couple of years has that
happened my guess is probably not so
keep them coming it's just fuel for the
fire and the fire is growing my friends
we've got a great bonus show coming up
for you today producer Pat wants to
weigh in on a number of different things
including Donald Trump's latest claims
about where he may or may not debate
join both of us on the bonus show today
join pakman.com patreon.com slash david
pakman show